I didn't want to become a star I wanted
to become the best player in Holland and
then I wanted to become the best player
in the world not about becoming a star
that's the issue of today
you
I think football has chosen me when I
was a little kid and I fell in love with
football before I even understood what
it was I was playing at 24/7 if possible
on the street in the classroom and at
home in my room avoiding my mom trying
to reach me
grabbed me and kicked me out of the
kitchen all of that helped a lot because
she will you had to be really really
agile because sometimes things will be
flying in the kitchen through your head
so at the same get out of here you know
with the ball all these things that that
you do naturally as a kid playing I'm
not playing only PlayStation is
fundamental I'm not saying don't play
playstation because we didn't had
PlayStation we had Atari then believe me
what's not the same but the fun we had
to play together to go out having to
avoid bicycles having to avoid sometimes
cars that would come out we created a
goal between two cars or all these
things as creativity it was helpful for
me and I know it now I didn't know then
but I know that it definitely helped me
from my 10th to my 16 when I start a
professional football all my weekends
practically all the vacation periods
where others could do whatever day what
and we were playing and go to
tournaments and truffling and and then
with 16 years 17 years we were in an
adult world working already
it wasn't easy to say to see them go and
have some fun
in the weekends sometimes you feel like
one thing to be with them and and those
were choices sacrifices one makes well
the level of excellence is what you
strive for decisions you make and the
efforts you make to first make sure
you're physically fit if you fit you can
play and and then you can complicate the
life of your coach if you not fit you
make your coach life very easy then you
need to be mentally fit as well if you
have the possibility read about stuff
read about how you can develop a strong
you know strong mentality how you can
deal with disappointments which is
obviously for everybody a very present
thing in our life what I do think is a
real sacrifice is just the little time
you spend with your family that is at
this time it isn't that you cannot take
back and that and that's for me the real
and probably only real sacrifice if we
have to talk about it and the return
isn't always what we want so we need to
enjoy it we need to support each other
in that in those phases and maximize the
moment you have what you found friends
and family so first of all I didn't want
to become a star I wanted to become the
best player in Holland and then I want
to become the best player in the world I
wanted to become champion of his
Champions League I wanted to win the
World Cup I wanted to those are the
dreams of young players is not about
becoming a star that's the issue of
today the day that when it become stars
but they don't become somebody who's
leave your legacy or become a winner in
football today it's about the likes
about the followers and which is a very
important I have nothing against it
absolutely not but that doesn't say
anything about the content it doesn't
say how good you have been it doesn't
say how much you have left behind in the
places you've been you've played for
indefinitely even what you have won
doesn't really last forever is the
impact you've had as a player as a
person and the places you have work with
and it's about the relationships that
you've built during the period of your
career that's what's really important do
whatever is needed because that's the
excellence the excellence is not the
final result always because there will
be a consequence of all the things you
do before
[Music]